rudd à nîmes est ce que vous vous la
première fois avec avec je peux quand il
s'appelle c'est vrai c'était il était
comment lui ponot content de lui
non mais tous nos champions n'ont écouté
il n'y avait pas âme ni avec quel
candidat il estime qu on a passé un toit
c'est bien la première fois au bénin oui
c'est peut-être tout c'était vraiment
benhalima reatard fin par une panne ou
d'amour c'est toujours bien voilà le
sujet des formidables isabelle dans vos
souvenirs clinique
oui la première fois sa compagne très
souvent n'existent items pour le salon
j'ai vu les bataillons michael jackson a
chanté émettre des précisions c'est la
première fois dans la vie qui amène la
cystite mais ce n'est pas la première
fois avec ton âme ouais bon elle s'élève
à l'abri cet ensemble c'est quoi le
rapport
mais d'après le rapport les noms mais
elle dit c'est la première fois qu'on le
sait mais moi c'était avec mon homme
donc ça change rien
oui en fait la première fois que la wii
la première fois qu'elle a ma vie avec
alan mais la première fois de votre vie
un deuxième temps deuxième parce que
vous avez voulu voir un mec caballé un 9
et 10 pour paris m arriver vierge pour
alain larivée ballon ça oui
alors oui au bout du bout moi c'était il
était conquérant flamboyant plein de
panache
moi c'est valable ouais ouais je sais
pas mais tim gunn accueilli cinq mois
les tankers fontaine bouclé raison avec
lequel elle marchait pas latéral de
bajur à jamie 2 sait pas où est la
première fois avec le premier
oui oui c'était ignoble ouais et après
les premières fois avec les nouveaux oui
c'était génial parce que quand il ya de
l'amour c'est génial on regarde la
moyenne
tétouan et josé luis compris kabar bail
avec 140 et août géraldine à raison vous
votre première fois vous êtes senti
comment son père andré penaud
oui comment de sa super fier elle a
d'ailleurs un des étoiles dans les yeux
elle a eu des étoiles partout sauf là
bas c'est une époque où on avait un
miroir pour vous regardez vous admirez
comme vous aimez bien faire ses
premières fois c'est vrai vous vous
regardez bouquet vous avez des panneaux
déjà ça me plairait paseo
aujourd'hui
les questions si vous avez eu des pannes
ce n'est pas grave on savait pas de nous
si ça ne sait jamais il peut parce que
les ailes très performant parfois de
temps en temps ça faisait un peu de
temps de dengue peut y avoir des moments
mais bon moi j'ai un emploi du temps
doux dingue me suis beaucoup regardé
soyons honnêtes les coups de mou ça peut
arriver aux meilleurs montrerai pas là
dedans il attend surtout que ça peut
être dû au stress c'est quoi jean-michel
je suis tout le monde était aussi
performant que j'ai fait dans ses
problèmes de couple
hop et là mon chéri c'était à quel âge
de savoir à quel âge tu vois 12 ans et
nous en sortir bien mais tu es fou quoi
construire toile quoi il avait rien il
ya pas eu d poids là
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
mais je vous dis nord
bah ouais tout 112,13 ces dernières fois
c'était quoi est la maison première fois
tu avais que deux jumelles je crois moi
j'ai très mal aux eyzies au début du
[Rires]
[Musique]
mois
les brunettes hier soir bouton d'arrêt
d'urgence
du coup quand même votre première fois
c'était avec des jumelles est ce que
c'est sur votre délire tout quoi mais
j'aimais les ja du tout pas du tout dans
ce monde où tout va du coup des raisons
plus maintenant